Hey Youtubers, it is Charlie
So, because of all the Arrow/Flash Spinoff news
I wanted to do a dedicated video
For the top 5 stories I think they should adapt
And I'll also try to explain
What kind of show I think it is going to be
They haven't said what the name is going to be
Like, what the title they are going to call it is
It could be All Stars, it could be The Atom
Because it is going to be an ensamble team up show
I think that they are going to pick from one of the DC Teams
Obviously they are not going to to let them use the name Justice League
But there is always Justice Society, there is always All Stars
Any variation on that, Infinity Inc, just think of all the teams that do not use the words "Justice League"
I still think that the Atom is going to be the quarterback of the team
and because there is still a lot of questions as to how its going to use Firestorm
I can't realy say a whole lot about that
Martin Stein is going to be on the show, that's all we know
we don't know if Robbie Amell is going to be on it
Just to add a little context, if you don't know about the history of this spin-off show
originaly it was just suposed to be for The Atom, it was going to be like his own show
but, I think they saw the Firestorm episodes and everyone responded so well to that character
that the CW was like, "please give us more Firestorm", and this was the easiest way for them to do it
without crowding Team Flash
That's one of the bad parts of having so many awesome guest actors on Arrow and The Flash
is that a lot of those actors can carry their own shows
but there is no room for them right now so that's what this new show is for
That's why Captain Cold, arguably a Rogue that should stay on The Flash, is going on the team up show
just because as an actor Wentworth Miller is so good he needs more screen time
but you can only use Captain Cold so much on The Flash
Given the characters that they have right now I'm choosing to think of this more like
a full-blown science bros show, like fair(?) science bros, so considering that
here are the top five I think they should adapt
starting from number five, Justice Society: Justice be done
this was the first new JSA story of the modern age, it was all about them putting the team back together
it featured Black Canary, Atom Smasher, the Jay Garrick Flash, Wildcat, Wonder Woman, Hourman
and a couple other lesser characters
they all come together to help the new Doctor Fate fight Mordru
as you can see they'd have to change some aspects of this
get rid of the magical elements and make more of and X-Files/C.S.I. tech based adventure show
like solving paranormal meta-human mysteries using Palmer Tech and Martin Stein science
regardless of wich story they choose to adapt, I mean, the tone of the show is going to flow
from the characters that they have
Firestorm and Atom, total science bros
Constantine and the new Lucifer show that FOX is doing, those are like the magic shows
so all the magic stuff is probably going to be localized to that
Of course they say 'that' you know, and then they'll probably announce some magic based
character for The flash season two
I feel like, that show has almost no limits
Moving on to number four tough, Brightest Day
So this a story where Ronnie Raymond came back from the dead and the Firestorm matrix starts acting all weird
Ronnie goes back to Pitsburg University to try and put his life back together
Gets into a fight with Jason Rusch and when Jason punches him they fuse into Firestorm
with Ronnie in control
it shows that early in the comics during the Infinite Crisis storyline Ronnie Raymond died
Jason Rusch took the mantle and became the Firestorm in the comics
So, Ronnie Raymond comes back and they have to figure out who is gonna be Firestorm
and what it is gonna look like
So you get Martin Stein off by himself just being Martin Stein in human form super smart scientist
and then you have two young characters flying around in Firestorm
Things got realy time wimey after that with the Deathstorm, like the Black Latern Firestorm
I don't think they are going to do that kind of stuff
But I do think that they are gonna change who gets to be inside the Firestorm matrix
I think that would go a long way towards how Martin Stein can be on the spin-off show without Robbie Amell
being on it and they being Firestorm together
So if Robbie Amell is gonna continue to be Firestorm and not be on the spin-off show
that means they are have to find a way to bring Jason Rusch into the equation
Moving on to number three, The Firestorm protocols
so this is a new 52 storyline where Ronnie Raymond and Jason Rusch
have to deal with a bunch of rogue Firestorms that have been created when other people
get their hands on Martin Stein Firestorm Protocols
that is basically blueprints for creating more Firestorms
They kinda teased this in The Flash episode 14 when General Eiling said
the military scientists found a way to extract the Firestorm matrix from Martin Stein body
if they did that they'd be able to replicate an army of Firestorms, that was what General Eiling
was trying to do
so that plotline is always gonna be a threat, there will always be people trying to steal the secret of Firestorm
Moving on to number two, The Fury of Firestorm
this was the very first story that they told in the new 52 Firestorm comics, right after Flashpoint
in this continuity Martin Stein is dead but he has given his research to Jason Rusch
and both Jason and Ronnie Raymond are able to become Firestorm on their own
so you have two diferent Firestorms at once
Martin Stein bequeathed something called "The God Particle" to Jason Rusch
it is just research of his based on the Firestorm matrix
it causes both Firestorms to fuse together into this mega combined Firestorm called The Fury
it is like the next evolution of Firestorm's powers so it is really interesting
hopefully they will deal with that on the show, they've been doing a lot of super power on The Flash
I think they will go full steam ahead on this spin-off show too
there is also a time as part of a earlier storyline when the atom actually shrinks down to go inside
the Firestorm Matrix and walk around and see what is happening
so there have actually been a lot of crossovers between Atom and Firestorm stories
so I imagine that was also discussion point when they were deciding
what kind of team up show this was gonna be
you get the general gist tough, you have The Atom, billionaire, just like Oliver Queen
funding this team of super heroes with this wise scientist Martin Stein helping them out
hopefully like and X-Files adventure show vibe, I'm really hoping for like, X-Files in the DC Universe
And this one is a total long shot, but my number one pick would be The Birth of The Red Tornado
remember how I said I'm expecting full blow science bros?
Well, what's the next logical step in that, that they haven't done in the TV DC Universe yet?
Artificial Intelligence
Right now there is very popular movie coming out soon that is dealing with that idea
and for those that haven't head the comics, yes Red Tornado total analogue of The Vision from Avengers
Evil villain creates an android to infiltrate superhero team and take them down
in the DC Universe T.O. Morrow is the scientist, that creates Red Tornado to take down the Justice League
the really cool thing is that, he used to work at Star Labs
because Star Labs is such a big thing on The Flash already, you already have this big point of crossover
to tell this huge story
so The Birth of The Red Tornado is just a point of Crossover for all of The CW shows
I mean, you could tie like the Supergirl show too but,
I'm not expecting has much crossover with that has I'm with shows that are on the same network
here is my big question for you guys
Wich storyline do you wanna see them adapt for this new spin-off show?
Just remember if Arrow can do batman stories then you can pick from
Justice League, any comic book story you want
There are a couple characters, that I'd really like to see them try and do
like Booster Gold, Red Tornado obviously at some point
I'm not expecting Green Lantern, I feel like he might be introduced in the movies first before we see him on TV
I know there are lots of Green Lanterns they could do, but I feel like DC would be really reticent
to let him appear on TV if they have a big movie planned for him
Just because so many of these shows are on diferent networks there are a lot of question about
who gets to use which side character, so hopefully by the time we get to Comic Con
all the networks will have announced who they've cast, which characters they are using
so we'll have a better what is it gonna look like
Here is a round up of all the diferent shows in the  diferent neworks
So on The CW we have 'Arrow', 'The Flash'
a Vixen Digital Cartoon, that's not gonna be on TV, that will be on the Web
and then now the Atom/Firestorm spin-off
At FOX there is Gotham, that is coming back for season two
Then there is the Lucifer show, that is actually part of the Neil Gaiman's Sandman Universe
CBS has Supergirl
TNT has the live action Teen Titan show
and NBC hasn't said anything about Constantine yet, so we'll just put a big question mark there
those are all the TV shows
I know I haven't done a lot of supergirl videos yet but I'll start doing some soon
While I was making this video they actually announced Dean Cain and Helen Slater are being cast for the pilot
that's a pretty big WTF, they didn't say who they are playing, they just said they are being cast in the pilot
so, no idea if they will return in recurring roles that could go beyond the show every week
it could be like a John Wesley Shipp thing where they play Kara's kriptonian parents
here is one really interesting thing that we need to think about
because Supergirl's origin is tied to the Bottled City of Kandor
I'm really interested to see if the is gonna go there or they are just gonna bypass that altogether
There is no way we are gonna make it throught Comic Con without people asking him those questions
so hopefully we will learn more pretty soon
the show itself is gonna be procedural because it is on CBS
So no idea, like how meta they are gonna get with comic book storylines
for those who are asking, yes I'm gonna be doing weekly videos for the show whenever it comes so
be sure to subscribe to get all that stuff, also doing bonus videos pretty soon too
I have no idea what the fall schedule is gonna be
Hopefully it all works out and all the shows don't air on the same day, that'd be a nightmare for me
because it is friday and I've already done a whole bunch of DC videos I think my next video
is going to be my Black Panther video that I keep putting off
So while you guys wait for that, you can click here to catch up on The Flash
and you can click here to catch up on Arrow
Thank you so much for watching, so let's all hight five, everybody live long and prosper
may you rest in peace Leonard Nimoy